I
kyra tirana berry 1987b a columbia
college I met my husband here he was
also the class in 1987 that has been a
major part of our life and our Columbia
community has been a part of our life
we're still very close with a lot of our
friends from from
my sophomore year bunch of women got
together and they wanted to put together
a soccer team you know we went up to
fake her field we were a small group you
know heading up there there were no
facilities for women up a bigger field
so we would go up every day and we would
change in the bathroom that was our
locker room and when we had games it was
the visiting and home locker room it was
a to stall bathroom there were
experiences like that that you felt that
you know okay we're you know breaking
new ground but I I think my experience
is being the first class of women it was
a much more notable experience when I
became involved as an alumni
part of what's exciting about being
involved at the college now is doing
Michelle moody Adams coming in it's just
it's a new doors opening it's a it's a
new direction and being involved with
that being involved with the first woman
dean of the college and being part of
the first class of you know coed class
those things together and looking at you
know the women alumni and specific
particular with this new woman Dean its
again many new opportunities how can
alumni be involved if not only to
benefit themselves but to benefit the
students that are here today I have to
be strengthen those relationships and
you know the stronger we make the
college today the stronger it is for us
and there's a benefit that goes both
ways I was honored to be given the
Alumni nettle and I have to say I was a
little bit taken aback you know I feel
you know in many ways I'm a very young a
mom in terms of my history of being
involved with Columbia yeah I do jump in
with both feet and enthusiastically and
what I decided to do something i do i do
it i don't do it part way
you